in this video we're going to establish a
nice property of the Poisson process
here is a setting we have a Poisson
process with arrival rate lambda and so
arrivals keep coming and we watch this
process until a certain random time T so
T is this time here now T is an
exponential random variable with some
parameter and T is independent from the
Poisson arrival process what we're
interested in is the number of arrivals
that happened during this time how can
we answer this question there are two
ways one is using mathematical
manipulations the other is using
intuition let's see what it would take
if we wanted to solve the problem using
formulas so let's call NT with capital T
the number of arrivals until time T in
our Poisson process and we wish to find
the distribution of n T so we want to
calculate for example the probability
that n T is equal to a specific number K
now we do not know very much about this
random variable but we do know the
probability of the random variable n T
if we have a deterministic time so
perhaps we can condition by fixing the
value of the random variable capital T
that is to condition on that random
variable taking on a specific value what
happens in this case well if I tell you
that capital T is equal to little T this
probability is going to be the same as
the probability that n with little T is
equal to K where n with little T is the
number of arrivals until time little T
but the number of arrivals until a
certain time is a Poisson random
variable so we do know what this
probability is it is lambda to the K e
to the lambda
T divided by K factorial now if we have
this conditional probability how can we
get the unconditional probability this
is done by using the total probability
theorem we consider all possible values
of little T which are all the numbers
from 0 to infinity we weigh each
possible value of little T according to
the corresponding PDF of the random
variable T and we have this equality we
know what this term is it is this
expression and the density of capital T
since it is an exponential random
variable the density takes this form and
so in order to find the distribution of
the random variable and capital T all
that we need to do is to calculate this
integral but this is a rather messy
integral so let us try to see if we can
find a shortcut to this problem so here
is what we have we have a Poisson
process
let's call it the first Poisson process
that has a certain rate lambda and this
Poisson process has arrivals at various
times and then we have a random variable
capital T which is exponential how
should we think about an exponential
random variable we can think of an
exponential random variable as being the
first arrival in some Poisson process so
let us put down the second Poisson
process with rate mu since we have
assumed that capital T is independent
from the red Poisson process we can just
assume that this blue Poisson process is
independent from the first now let us
merge the two processes
and we're going to form the merged
process that records an arrival at those
times at which either of the two
processes have an arrival this is the
time of interest and the random variable
that we're interested in is the number
of red arrivals until that time that
random variable we call n capital T the
discussion will be a little simpler if
we define another random variable K
which is n capital T plus one so K is
the number of arrivals in the merged
process until this time that is we take
those arrivals of the red process and we
also include that arrival here so if the
number of arrivals that we got here was
n capital T here we have arrivals one
two and so on and this is arrival number
K so k is a random variable and we want
to find what it is so what are we asking
what is K K is the number of arrivals in
the merged process until you get an
arrival in the merged process which is
coming from the blue process
and now here is how we can think of this
situation think of each arrival in the
merged process as a trial
each one of these arrivals is coming
either from the read process or from the
blue process let us call it a success if
it comes from the blue process
so in that case K is the number of
trials until we have a success K is the
number of arrivals in the merged process
until we have a successful arrival
meaning one that came out of the blue
process so what do we know about those
trials what are their statistical
properties first what is the probability
of success the probability of success is
the probability that when you get an
arrival in the merged process it is
coming from the blue process and as we
have seen given an arrival in emerged in
the mers process there is probability
that it's coming from this particular
process that's proportional to the
arrival rate of that particular process
and it is equal as we have discussed
before it is equal to this in addition
we have discussed that when you look at
the merged process and you ask what was
the origin of that arrival and you ask
what was the origin of that arrival the
answers to these two questions are
independent of each other in other words
the origin of this arrival is
statistically independent from the
origin of that arrival so this means
that these trials are independent so
what we're looking at is a random
variable which is the number of trials
until the first success in a sequence of
independent trials where each trial has
a success probability equal to that
value and we know quantity distribution
is it is a geometric with this
particular parameter this gives us the
probability distribution of the random
variable K and once you have the PMF of
K you just shift it by one to the left
in order to get the probability
distribution the PMF of the random
variable n capital T and so this is the
answer to this problem the number of
arrivals during an exponentially
distributed time interval is a geometric
distribution that's shifted by one to
the left